[Music]
you all know the dating site Ashley
Madison right okay oh do you usually
don't weigh in at that part no I don't
know anything about it yeah the dating
site Ashley Madison which became famous
for encouraging people to cheat on their
spouses has announced they are dropping
their old slogan which was life's short
have an affair that was their old slogan
they have now rebranded themselves with
a new slogan that says find your moment
yeah well we looked into it apparently
they were considering a ton of other
slogans at Ashley Madison before landing
unfine your moment we got a hold of just
a couple of them for example there was
this one right here who's up for some
side ass that was okay
there was this thermite here Ashley
Madison because your spouse blows that
it was this one because your spouse
doesn't blow
there was this one we live once then
it's a dirt nap so screw away then there
was because it's fun to bang your
neighbor in a library parking lot there
is where the discrete sophisticated
lothario goes to get some stinky on his
dinky there was this one don't keep your
badly lit bathroom dick pic all to
yourself
[Applause]
there was this one now it's four percent
more female accounts than World of
Warcraft
there was this our bots will love your
average size penis
there was this the safe discreet way to
eventually lose custody of your children
there's this one lots of slots is what
we got
written by our own Andy rector there's
this one there was this one it's st
dee-lightful and finally sorry about all
the lies we've ruined now let's get our
[Applause]
you